wanted to get a hold of Joseph Goodman
he's Alabama dot-com sports columnist
and he had a recent article clipper Wars
LeBron James versus Nick Saban because
both have shows and you've had LeBron
called out Nick Saban that you know he's
doing something that he think it thinks
is sort of a ripoff of what LeBron came
up with so Joseph Goodman joins us now
thanks for joining us Joseph so where do
we stand with this it you know how
serious is this feud between these two I
can't take this seriously there's no way
that this can be taken seriously in a
court of law
it's not it's not gonna hold water we
know that but you know LeBron has long
had his internet videos or
self-promotion anchored around a
barbershop now Nick Saban has his
internet video anchored around
self-promotion and a barbershop
so yeah the fight is on the Clipper war
but Sabin did change the name of his
show to Bama talk does that change
anything here is he a Qui asking to to
LeBron I think so I think one this one
yeah Nick Nick changed it to Bama cuts
it was shop Talk and LeBrons was the
shop yeah so that was pretty similar you
know to put a great line from the movie
coming to America you have McDonald's
I have McDowell but also Joseph you'd be
look at this LeBron is taking from move
and you know the movie barbershop right
I mean come on exactly we're talking
about exclusive intellectual property
yes yeah what do you make of Nick
saint-like Saban kind of going back with
LeBron a little bit here Saban doesn't
back down how did this play locally in
Alabama
well locally everyone and all the
Alabama fans are always going to take
Nick Saban side on everything it doesn't
matter what it is but you know
one thing that needs to be pointed out
is Nick saving both Nick's David and
LeBron James don't get enough credit for
being showman I don't think and it was
brilliant on the bronze part I think to
point out in the middle of nowhere he's
created a story have nothing about a
barbershop chef that no one ever watches
and now if you have it's a win-win for
everyone as far as I'm concerned because
the only reason Nick Saban has this
thing is for recruiting and people are
gonna watch the broad James's barbershop
show maybe a little more I'm not sure do
you think I do want to yeah go ahead go
ahead
I just want to point out these shows
okay are both barbershop webseries shows
man the barbers don't ever say anything
all they do is shut up and cut that's
right the spirit of the barbershop show
doesn't necessarily live in these shows
you know what LeBron thing I know LeBron
being an Ohio State fan do you think
that has anything to do with this what
if LeBron showed up with a Cam Newton
like Auburn Jersey on it has something
to do this is a guy who during the
during the incident tournament he he
does not come out for interviews if he's
watching an Ohio State game and during
the football season he's the exact same
way I mean yeah yeah I used to cover the
Miami Heat for the Miami Herald when the
Brawn was down there before I moved to
Alabama to be a columnist and the first
thing that Urban Meyer did when he
became coach at Ohio State was fly down
to Miami sit outside the Heath's locker
room after a game and then get
one-on-one time with the Brawn I mean he
had to kiss the rings okay and LeBron
carried so much power with his words
that you got to think that if he's going
to call out
Aven you know kids in Ohio we're gonna
listen to that and maybe watch it Joseph
I'll try to bother you with something
far more serious the next time all right
thanks for joining us from being a good
sport I think that I Joseph Goodman the
Alabama comm sports columnist yeah
Paulie the Knicks Haven cave on this one
did he just it feels like it feels like
he altered the now full disclosure I
didn't know LeBron had a show and I
didn't know that Nick Saban had a show
now everybody knows they have a show so
you know maybe we got played here new
poll question LeBron Sabin scripted real
novi genius that would have been genius
probably not scripted but man out of Ben
genius feels like it was it was
manipulated a little bit there they they
manipulated us well done well done
four more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]